for us
there's only one person
who could play that role
only one
and she's here
let me introduce her to you now please
welcome the stage natalie portman
[Applause]
[Music]
ever since natalie portman hit hall h at
comic con in 2019 holding the hammer of
thor marvel fans have been waiting to
see her in full goddess of thunder
costume and thanks to the thor love and
thunder teaser trailer you finally got
it
[Music]
now for those of you not familiar with
the comics you might be asking yourself
how does jane foster possess the power
of thor well the answer in the comics
can be found in the pages of thor volume
4 from 2014. when thor odinson becomes
unworthy to carry mjolnir a mysterious
new heroine appears in the marvel
universe with the hammer in hand comic
writer jason aaron and artist russell
daughterman took over the thor comics in
2012 and completed a seven year run of
godly drama he not only introduced jane
as thor but another character we'll see
in love and thunder gore the god butcher
an anti-theist alien held bent on
killing every god in the universe in
order to free mortals from believing in
them christian bale is taking on the big
screen adaptation we can't wait to see
what he does with it in a 2014 interview
aaron spoke about his decision to
introduce jane as the new thor telling
comic book resources quote you pick up
this book and it just says thor on the
cover which features a new female
version of thor it's pretty much telling
you she's not she thor or lady thor
she's not thorica she is thor this is
the new thor the comics kept the new
thor's identity a secret for seven
months eventually revealing the truth
thor was dr jane foster stricken with
cancer transforming into the goddess of
thunder was a double-edged sword for
jane as thor she was nearly invincible
and free of sickness but each time she
changed back into her human form the
cancer got worse we don't know if that
particular element of her story will
make it onto the big screen but the
simple fact that she's finally here
opens up a ton of storytelling
possibilities his hands were once used
for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
exactly who i am
the opening shot of the teaser shifts
between three different phases in the
life of chris hemsworth thor which shows
off a comic's accurate depiction of
thor's original costume and reflects the
influence of aaron's comics as well
although there is no sign of the old
white-haired king thor at the end of
time on a post-apocalyptic earth that's
actually my favorite thor gotta keep
something for the actual trailer though
right and hey the doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness in theaters on may
6 you know anything is possible
i want to choose my own path
live in the moment
my superhero superheroing days are over
now back in 2019 our very own keisha
shantae spoke with director taika
waititi about what fans can expect from
natalie's performance i don't think
there would have been really been much
point in her character coming back and
just doing the same thing i think now
shifting that and like you know her
becoming part of the um elevating to
this level of superhero um is going to
be something really good for the
franchise and for
and for
us
introducing more strong female
characters in the mcu and um
yeah so she's yeah
i couldn't be happier
if tike is happy then we're happy and i
definitely agree seeing more powerful
female characters in the mcu is never a
bad thing so what do you think about the
teaser trailer are you looking forward
to seeing natalie portman become the
mighty thor as always drop your thoughts
in the comments below and we'll see you
wednesday for our mid-season moon night
panel bye
you